This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Since the mid 1970s, almost every jazz musician has owned a copy of the same book. It has a peach-colored cover, a chunky 70s style logo, and black plastic binding. It is delightfully homemade looking, like it was printed by a bunch of teenagers at KINGO's. And inside is the sheet music for hundreds of common jazz tunes, also known as jazz standards, all meticulously notated by hand. It's called The Real Book.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。自20世纪70年代中期以来，几乎每位爵士乐手都拥有一本同样的书。它有着桃色的封面、粗犷的70年代风格标志，以及黑色的塑料装订。它看起来非常像手工制作的，就像是一群青少年在KINGO复印店印出来的一样。书里收录了数百首常见爵士乐曲（也称为爵士标准曲）的乐谱，全部都是用手精心记谱的。它被称为《Real Book》。
When I started playing jazz, I remember the first thing like a tar teacher said was, well, you gotta buy a real book. That's producer Mikael McAfinow. Everybody had one. It just felt like something you were expected to own if you were a serious musician. My high school jazz teacher, Mr. Leonard, had stacks of real books on his desk. And he told me that he actually got his first real book at the place where they were originally published,
当我开始学习爵士乐时，我记得我的第一位老师说的第一件事就是：“好吧，你得买一本《Real Book》。”那是制作人米凯尔·麦卡菲诺。每个人都有一本。如果你是一名认真的音乐家，这似乎是你理应拥有的东西。我的高中爵士乐老师伦纳德先生的桌子上堆满了《Real Book》。他告诉我，他实际上是在最初出版这些书的地方买到了他的第一本《Real Book》，
Berkeley College of Music in Boston. He had just arrived for his freshman year. I heard people talking about the real book, the real book, it was just all around Berk. They were everywhere, everywhere. You were told when you had an ensemble, bring a real book we're gonna do with students out of that.
也就是波士顿的伯克利音乐学院。他刚到那里读大一。我听到人们谈论《Real Book》，到处都在谈论它，它在伯克利无处不在。到处都是。当你参加合奏课时，老师会告诉你：“带上《Real Book》，我们要用它来练习。”
But pretty quickly Mr. Leonard discovered that the real book wasn't like the other books he needed to get for his classes. You couldn't just buy a copy in the campus bookstore. There was a guy who used to stand on the corner of Massive Near Boilsen Street and he had a box and he would sit there and he'd just, yeah, you want to put him on a real book, you want to buy a real book, that kind of thing.
但很快，伦纳德先生发现《Real Book》和他上课需要的其他书不一样。你不能直接在校园书店买到。以前有个家伙常站在马萨诸塞大道和博伊尔斯顿街的拐角处，他带着一个盒子坐在那儿，如果你问他：“你想买本《Real Book》吗？”他就会卖给你。
From Mr. Leonard's description, this guy basically sounded like he wandered out of a ZZ top concert. You know, jeans really, really long, like mid-back level hair, big beard. And as I understood it, he used to get arrested about once every two weeks. He would get arrested because the real book was illegal. The world's most popular collection of jazz music was a totally unlicensed publication. A janky, self-published book created without permission
根据伦纳德先生的描述，这家伙听起来就像是从ZZ Top乐队的演唱会上走出来的。你知道的，牛仔裤非常非常长，头发长到后背中部，留着大胡子。据我所知，他大约每两周就会被捕一次。他被捕是因为《Real Book》是非法的。这本世界上最受欢迎的爵士乐集是一本完全未经授权的出版物。这是一本粗制滥造、自费出版的书，是在没有获得音乐出版商或词曲作者许可的情况下创作的。
from music publishers or songwriters. It was duplicated at photocopy shops and sold on street corners, out of the trunks of cars, and under the table at music stores, where people used secret code words to make the exchange. The full story of how the Wiggle book came to be this bootleg bible of jazz is a complicated one.
它在复印店被复制，在街角、汽车后备箱里以及乐器店的柜台下出售，人们用暗号来进行交易。关于这本“摇摆书”如何成为爵士乐的盗版圣经，其完整故事非常复杂。
It's a story about what happens when an insurgent improvisational art form like jazz gets codified and becomes something you can learn from a book. Barry Kernfeld is a musicologist who's written a lot about the history of jazz and music piracy. He's also a saxophonist, and at a coffee shop gig in the 1990s, he was opening his real book.
这是一个关于当像爵士乐这样具有反叛性的即兴艺术形式被编纂成书，并成为你可以从中学习的东西时会发生什么的故事。巴里·克恩菲尔德是一位音乐学家，他写过很多关于爵士乐历史和音乐盗版的文章。他也是一位萨克斯手，在20世纪90年代的一次咖啡馆演出中，他打开了他的《Real Book》。
And I started wondering, well, we're reading all these tunes and learning to play and where did the book come from. Kernfeld says that long before the real book ever came out, jazz musicians were relying on collections of music they called fake books. And the story of the first fake book begins in the 1940s. Man named George Goodwin in New York City, involved heavily in radio in the early 1940s, was getting a little frustrated with all the intricacies of tracking licensing.
“我开始纳闷，我们演奏着所有这些曲子，学习如何演奏，但这本书到底是从哪儿来的呢？”克恩菲尔德说，早在《Real Book》问世之前，爵士乐手们就依赖于他们称之为“假书”（fake books）的乐谱集。第一本“假书”的故事始于20世纪40年代。纽约市一位名叫乔治·古德温的人，在40年代初深度参与广播事业，他对追踪版权许可的复杂性感到有些沮丧。
And so he invented this thing that he called the Tune Dex. The Tune Dex was an index card catalog design for radio station employees to keep track of the songs they were playing on air. On one side, the cards a few lines of bite-sized, cheap music, just the song's melody, lyrics, and chords, so that radio station employees could glance at it and quickly recall the song. But this abbreviated musical notation also made the cards useful to another group of people. And on the other side, they had a few lines of bite-sized, cheap music, just the song's melody, lyrics, and chords, so that radio station employees could glance at it and quickly recall the song. But this abbreviated musical notation also made the cards useful to another group of people,
于是他发明了一种叫做“Tune Dex”的东西。Tune Dex是一种索引卡片目录，旨在让广播电台员工追踪他们在节目中播放的歌曲。卡片的一面有几行简短、廉价的乐谱，只有歌曲的旋律、歌词和和弦，这样广播电台员工扫一眼就能快速回忆起这首歌。但这种简化的乐谱也让这些卡片对另一群人很有用。卡片的另一面也有几行简短、廉价的乐谱，只有歌曲的旋律、歌词和和弦，这样广播电台员工扫一眼就能快速回忆起这首歌。但这种简化的乐谱也让这些卡片对另一群人很有用，
working jazz musicians. As a black art form, jazz had developed out of a mix of other black music traditions, including spirituals in the blues. By the 40s, a lot of jazz was popular dance music, and many jazz musicians were making their money playing live gigs in small clubs and bars. The standard jazz repertoire was mostly well-known songs from Broadway, or New York songwriting factory, Tin Pan Alley, like the song Night and Day, by Tin Pan Alley legend, Cole Porter. Jazz musicians would riff and freestyle over these songs.
那就是职业爵士乐手。作为一种黑人艺术形式，爵士乐融合了其他黑人音乐传统，包括灵歌和蓝调。到了40年代，许多爵士乐是流行的舞蹈音乐，许多爵士乐手靠在小俱乐部和酒吧里进行现场演出赚钱。标准的爵士乐曲目大多是来自百老汇或纽约歌曲创作工厂“廷潘巷”的知名歌曲，比如廷潘巷传奇人物科尔·波特创作的《Night and Day》。爵士乐手会围绕这些歌曲进行即兴创作和自由发挥。
That's always been a key part of jazz, the art of improvisation. But what made the average gigging trumpeter or sax player truly valuable was their ability to play any one of hundreds of songs, right there on the spot. In the 1940s, people are working steadily as musicians, playing piano and nightclubs, or playing in a small group in nightclubs, fulfilling requests. You know, the cliche of the drunken guy at the egg, and you play, I love my art, and the San Francisco. To be prepared for any drunken request, musicians would bring stacks and stacks of sheet music to every gig. But lugging around a giant pile of paper was really cumbersome.
即兴创作一直是爵士乐的关键部分。但让普通的小号手或萨克斯手真正有价值的是他们能够当场演奏数百首歌曲中的任何一首。在20世纪40年代，人们作为音乐家稳定工作，在夜总会弹钢琴，或在小团体中演奏，满足听众的点歌要求。你知道，那个在演出时喝醉的家伙点歌的陈词滥调，你得演奏《I Love My Art》或者《San Francisco》。为了应对任何醉酒后的点歌要求，音乐家们会带上一大堆乐谱去参加每场演出。但拖着一大堆纸真的很麻烦。
And that's where the tune decks came in. Someone figured out that you could gather a bunch of tune decks cards, print copies of them on sheets of paper, add a table of contents and a simple binding, and then sell the finished product directly to musicians in the form of a book. They called them fake books because they helped musicians fake their way through unfamiliar songs. These first fake books were cheaper than regular sheet music and a lot more organized and they became an essential tool for this entire class of working musicians. And then they could bring that to gigs instead of having to draw through piles of sheet music and try to keep each individual sheet in alphabetical order what a nightmare.
这就是Tune Dex派上用场的地方。有人想出，你可以收集一堆Tune Dex卡片，把它们印在纸上，加上目录和简单的装订，然后直接以书的形式卖给音乐家。他们称之为“假书”，因为它们帮助音乐家在不熟悉的歌曲中“伪装”过去。这些早期的假书比普通的乐谱便宜，而且更有条理，成为了这类职业音乐家的必备工具。这样他们就可以带着书去演出，而不必在成堆的乐谱中翻找，还要试图按字母顺序排列每一张纸，那简直是一场噩梦。
You have your bound little book of 300 tunes or 500 tunes or a thousand tunes and that became the first popular music fake book. And that became the first popular music fake book. Musicians loved these new fake books, but the music publishers, not so much. They wanted musicians to buy their sheet music, and so the publishing companies started cracking down on fake book bootleggers. The music publishers did everything they could
你有一本装订好的小书，里面有300首、500首或1000首曲子，这就是第一本流行的音乐假书。音乐家们喜欢这些新的假书，但音乐出版商却不这么认为。他们希望音乐家购买他们的乐谱，因此出版公司开始打击假书盗版商。音乐出版商竭尽所能，
FBI investigations and federal trials in order to suppress this new way of distributing music. But that didn't stop the bootleggers. And by the 1950s, there were countless illegal fake books in existence, which were being used in nightclubs all across the country. But as helpful as fake books were, they had a lot of problems. They were notoriously illegible and confusingly laid out.
包括联邦调查局的调查和联邦审判，以压制这种新的音乐分发方式。但这并没有阻止盗版商。到了20世纪50年代，市面上出现了无数非法的假书，它们被用于全国各地的夜总会。但尽管假书很有用，它们也有很多问题。它们以难以辨认和排版混乱而闻名。
It can't be stressed enough how deficient the old fake books were in this regard, how impossible to read and how stupidly misrepresented they were on the page. Steve Swallow is a jazz musician and an all-around good guy. A swell guy. I was like, you know, a thought of as a swell guy. I'm a bass player and I write tunes. That's the salient fact of my life. That's it.
怎么强调旧假书在这方面的缺陷都不为过，它们在页面上是多么难以阅读，多么愚蠢地被错误呈现。史蒂夫·斯沃洛是一位爵士乐手，也是一个全方位的好人。一个很棒的人。“我被认为是一个很棒的人。我是一名贝斯手，我写曲子。这是我生活中最突出的事实。就是这样。”
Starting off as a young jazz musician in the 1950s, Swallow played it clubs and dances and weddings and bar mitzvahs. And for a lot of these gigs, he relied on these poorly designed fake books. Working on jazz music seriously, one of the first things I did was to buy a fake book, and so we're just vexing and badly, badly written. The other big problem with these fake books at this point was that the music inside felt
作为20世纪50年代的一名年轻爵士乐手，斯沃洛在俱乐部、舞会、婚礼和犹太成人礼上演奏。对于许多这些演出，他依赖于这些设计糟糕的假书。“认真从事爵士乐工作时，我做的第一件事就是买一本假书，它们真的很令人恼火，写得非常非常糟糕。”这些假书在当时面临的另一个大问题是，里面的音乐感觉
really out of date. The fake books hadn't changed since the mid-40s, but jazz had. Disillusioned by commercial jazz that appealed to mainstream white audiences, a new generation of black musicians took jazz improvisation to a new level, experimenting with more angular harmonies, technically demanding melodies, and blindingly fast tempos. Their new style was called Bebop. That was Bebop legend Charlie Parker, and Bebop was just the beginning, then came Hardbop and modal jazz spearheaded by Miles Davis.
非常过时。假书自40年代中期以来就没有变过，但爵士乐变了。对迎合主流白人听众的商业爵士乐感到幻灭，新一代黑人音乐家将爵士即兴创作提升到了一个新的水平，尝试更尖锐的和声、技术要求更高的旋律和快得惊人的节奏。他们的新风格被称为“比波普”（Bebop）。那是比波普传奇查理·帕克，而比波普只是开始，接着是硬波普（Hardbop）和由迈尔斯·戴维斯领衔的调式爵士（modal jazz）。
Then you had the wild, dissonant, free jazz of people like Ornette Coleman. And the electrified jazz fusion of Herbie Hancock. By the 1970s, jazz had exploded into this constellation of different styles. Meanwhile, the economics of jazz had shifted too. There were fewer clubs and smaller paychecks. University jazz programs also started popping up around this time, providing steady teaching gigs to established musicians, and increasingly, the ivory tower became a place for young musicians to learn. And if you're going to jazz school, you need jazz books.
然后是像奥内特·科尔曼那样狂野、不和谐的自由爵士（free jazz），以及赫比·汉考克的电子爵士融合乐。到了20世纪70年代，爵士乐已经爆发成一系列不同的风格。与此同时，爵士乐的经济状况也发生了变化。俱乐部少了，报酬也少了。大学爵士乐课程也在这段时间开始涌现，为资深音乐家提供了稳定的教学工作，象牙塔也越来越多地成为年轻音乐家学习的地方。如果你要上爵士乐学校，你需要爵士乐书籍。
But the fake books at the time hadn't kept up with the music. They still contained the same old-fashioned collection of standards with the same old-fashioned collection of chord changes. So if a young jazz musician wanted to try and play like Charles Mingus or Sonny Rollins, they weren't going to learn from a book. That is, until two college kids invented the real book. I don't want to overemphasize my role in it, which was minor, but I knew the guys.
但当时的假书并没有跟上音乐的发展。它们仍然包含着同样老式的标准曲集，以及同样老式的和弦进行。所以，如果一个年轻的爵士乐手想尝试像查尔斯·明格斯或桑尼·罗林斯那样演奏，他们是无法从书中学到的。直到两个大学生发明了《Real Book》。“我不想过分强调我在其中的作用，虽然很小，但我认识那些家伙。”
In the mid-70s, Steve Swallow began teaching at Boston's Berkeley College of Music, an elite private music school that boasted one of the first jazz performance programs in the country. Swallow had only been teaching at Berkeley for a few months when two students approached him about a secret project. I keep referring to them as the two guys who wrote the book because way back when they swore me to secrecy, they made me agree that I would not divulge their names." The two guys wanted to make a new fake book, one that actually catered to the needs of contemporary jazz musicians and reflected the current state of jazz, and they needed Steve's help. That's how they pitched it. They pitched it that they wanted to write a fake book that
70年代中期，史蒂夫·斯沃洛开始在波士顿的伯克利音乐学院任教，这是一所精英私立音乐学校，拥有全国首批爵士乐表演课程之一。斯沃洛在伯克利教书才几个月，就有两名学生找到他，谈论一个秘密项目。“我一直称他们为‘写书的那两个家伙’，因为很久以前他们让我发誓保密，他们让我同意不泄露他们的名字。”这两个家伙想制作一本新的假书，一本真正满足当代爵士乐手需求并反映爵士乐现状的假书，他们需要史蒂夫的帮助。这就是他们的推销方式。他们推销说，他们想写一本假书，
would actually be useful to an 18-year-old person who wanted to become a jazz musician. As a longtime user of some pretty horrible fake books, Steve was excited. He thought that a modern, well-made jazz fake book would be an essential improvement for his students. And indeed, that was part of my initial response to their pitch. I thought, geez, it's why didn't I think of this?"
“对一个想成为爵士乐手的18岁年轻人来说，这真的很有用。”作为一些非常糟糕的假书的长期用户，史蒂夫很兴奋。他认为一本现代、制作精良的爵士假书对他学生来说将是一个重要的改进。事实上，这也是我最初回应他们推销的一部分。我想，天哪，为什么我没想到这一点呢？
But he was also torn. He knew the students couldn't possibly pay licensing fees for all the songs they wanted to include. So he had to decide whether helping them was the right thing to do. Because clearly their intention was to break the law. They would also be selling a book filled with other people's music. But in the end, Swallow decided that the need for a good jazz fake book was so great that it was worth it, and he agreed to help. Swallow and the students were going to make a fake book that would actually be useful to a young person trying to play jazz. A real fake book.
但他也很纠结。他知道学生们不可能为他们想收录的所有歌曲支付许可费。所以他必须决定帮助他们是否是正确的做法。因为很明显，他们的意图是违法。他们还将出售一本装满他人音乐的书。但最终，斯沃洛认为对一本好的爵士假书的需求如此之大，以至于值得冒险，他同意提供帮助。斯沃洛和学生们要制作一本对试图演奏爵士乐的年轻人来说真正有用的假书。一本“真正的”假书。
A real book. From the very beginning, the students envisioned the Real Book as a cooler and more contemporary fake book than the staggy, outdated ones they'd grown up with, they wanted to include new songs from modern jazz musicians who were pushing the boundaries of the genre. They also wanted to include the old jazz standards from Broadway and Tin Pan Alley, but they wanted to update those classics with alternate chord changes that reflected the way that modern musicians like Miles Davis were actually playing them.
一本《Real Book》。从一开始，学生们就设想《Real Book》要比他们成长过程中那些陈旧、过时的假书更酷、更现代。他们想收录现代爵士乐手的原创歌曲，这些乐手正在推动流派的边界。他们也想收录来自百老汇和廷潘巷的老爵士标准曲，但他们想用反映像迈尔斯·戴维斯这样的现代音乐家实际演奏方式的替代和弦进行来更新这些经典。
And Miles Davis was a central figure in all of this and he kind of exhumed dozens, I would say, of Tin Pan Alley tunes. And he and his sideman notably as pianist had smooth the harmonies in a way that became definitive. One of those standard tunes is someday my prince will come, a song from the 1937 Disney movie musical Snow White. Here's the original. And here's the Miles Davis version from 1961, the version that the students decided to put in the real book.
“迈尔斯·戴维斯是这一切的核心人物，他挖掘了数十首廷潘巷的曲子。他和他的伴奏乐手，特别是钢琴家，以一种成为定义性的方式平滑了和声。”其中一首标准曲是《Someday My Prince Will Come》，这是1937年迪士尼音乐动画片《白雪公主》中的一首歌。这是原版。这是1961年迈尔斯·戴维斯的版本，也就是学生们决定放入《Real Book》的版本。
It's the same song, but listen to how different, how complex the chord sound when played by pianist Wynton Kelly. Modern jazz musicians had altered a lot of classic standards in this way over the years, and to capture these sophisticated alternate chord changes, the two students spent hours listening to recordings and transcribing what they heard, as best they could. It was a huge undertaking because most of these chord changes had never actually been written down. They weren't necessarily thinking about it like this at the time, but the students were effectively establishing a new set of standardized harmonies for a handful of classic songs.
这是同一首歌，但听听当由钢琴家温顿·凯利演奏时，和弦听起来有多么不同、多么复杂。多年来，现代爵士乐手以这种方式改变了许多经典标准曲，为了捕捉这些复杂的替代和弦进行，两名学生花了数小时听录音，并尽可能地转录他们听到的内容。这是一项巨大的工程，因为这些和弦进行中的大多数实际上从未被写下来过。他们当时并不一定是以这种方式思考的，但学生们实际上是在为少数几首经典歌曲建立一套新的标准化和声。
But the music wasn't the only part of their new fake book that the two students wanted to improve. They also wanted to fix the aesthetic problems with the old fake books and make something that was nice to look at an easy to read. One of the two guys had a gorgeous music hand, the way he formed his quarter notes and his safe notes and all of that was lovely. And his role in the book among other things, he did all the actual penmanship. It's one guy who wrote the entire book.
但音乐并不是两名学生想要改进的新假书的唯一部分。他们还想解决旧假书的美学问题，制作出一种看起来美观且易于阅读的东西。“其中一个家伙有一手漂亮的音乐手写体，他形成四分音符和休止符的方式等等都很可爱。他在书中的角色，除其他事项外，是他完成了所有的实际书写。”是一个人写了整本书。
He notated all of the music by hand in this very distinctive and expressive script. He also designed and silkscreened the logo on the front cover, just the words, the real book, written in chunky, schoolhouse rock style block letters. And holding everything together was a plastic binding that let the book easily lie flat on a music stand. By the summer of 1975, the book was done, and the students took it to local photocopying shops where they cranked out hundreds of copies to sell directly to other students and a few local businesses near Berkeley.
他用这种非常独特且富有表现力的字体手写了所有的音乐。他还设计并丝网印刷了封面上的标志，只是“The Real Book”这几个字，用粗犷的“学校摇滚”风格的块状字母书写。把一切固定在一起的是一种塑料装订，让书可以很容易地平放在乐谱架上。到1975年夏天，书完成了，学生们把它带到当地的复印店，在那里他们印制了数百份，直接卖给其他学生和伯克利附近的一些当地企业。
There was a corner store called the Bentley Smoker, which was not a music shop. It was just everybody smoked and and it was a cigarette store. And beneath the counter, it was a stack of real books. And almost overnight, everybody had to have one. Including my old jazz teacher, Mr. Leonard. He bought a copy of the real book from that guy with the long hair on Mass Ave. On Mass Ave, I think it was 20 bucks,
“有一个叫Bentley Smoker的街角商店，那不是一家乐器店。每个人都抽烟，那是一家香烟店。在柜台下面，有一堆《Real Book》。”几乎一夜之间，每个人都必须拥有一本。包括我的老爵士乐老师伦纳德先生。他从马萨诸塞大道上那个长头发的家伙那里买了一本《Real Book》。“在马萨诸塞大道上，我想是20美元，”
which was steep at that point. You know, it was like, wow, okay, but that's what you needed. It was like buying a school book, you know? In fact, I used it more than some of my textbooks for classrooms. Mainly, he used it with other students in late-night jam sessions in the practice rooms.
“这在当时很贵。你知道，就像是，哇，好吧，但这就是你所需要的。这就像买一本学校课本，你知道吗？事实上，我用它的次数比我的一些课堂教科书还要多。”主要是，他在练习室的深夜即兴演奏会上和其他学生一起使用它。
Anybody could go in and play, and of course, there were a lot of them because it was a big school. And if you walked in with your book, you couldn't participate and be a part of it. Mr. Leonard says the real book helped everyone get on the same page really quickly. And Steve Swallow notices too. Before the real book came out, he used to walk by the practice rooms and hear students mangling the chord changes to all of these jazz tunes.
“任何人都可以进去演奏，当然，因为这是一所大学校，所以人很多。如果你带着你的书走进去，你就不能参与其中。”伦纳德先生说，《Real Book》帮助每个人非常快地达成共识。史蒂夫·斯沃洛也注意到了这一点。在《Real Book》问世之前，他过去常走过练习室，听到学生们把所有这些爵士乐曲的和弦进行搞得一团糟。
And all of a sudden the real book came along and I was making this same walk and hearing the right changes to I love you and the right changes to my funny Valentine's. Whoa! This is remarkable. As the Reel Books No Daryl grew, so did the demand. The two students hadn't printed enough copies to keep up, but it turns out they didn't need to. Not long after they published, you know, a few hundred photocopied versions of this book, somebody else photocopied the book and started selling it. And copies of the copies were
“突然间《Real Book》出现了，我走同样的路线，听到《I Love You》正确的和弦，听到《My Funny Valentine》正确的和弦。哇！这太了不起了。”随着《Real Book》的名声增长，需求也随之增长。两名学生印制的副本不足以跟上需求，但事实证明他们不需要。在他们出版了（你知道）几百份这本书的复印版后不久，其他人复印了这本书并开始出售。这些副本的副本
fanning out to New York City in LA and then beyond to Berlin and Shanghai and so on. The real book had taken on a life of its own, and the students ironically found themselves in the same position as the music publishers and songwriters that they'd originally cut out of the process as they watched unlicensed copies of their work get duplicated and sold. And of course they were in no position to yell about. They kind of had to just shake their heads. After they released the first edition of The Real Book, the students put out two more additions to correct mistakes, and then their work was done.
传到了纽约市和洛杉矶，然后传到了柏林、上海等等。这本书有了自己的生命，讽刺的是，学生们发现自己处于与他们最初从过程中剔除的音乐出版商和词曲作者相同的境地，因为他们看着自己作品的未经授权副本被复制和出售。当然，他们无法对此大喊大叫。他们只能摇摇头。在发行了《Real Book》的第一版后，学生们又推出了两个版本来纠正错误，然后他们的工作就完成了。
But The Real Book lived on, copied over and over again by new generations of bootleggers. Steve Swallow doesn't take the copyright issue lightly, but he thinks the real book was bootleggers. When he agreed to help the students, Swallow actually donated a bunch of his own songs. He figured it would benefit him in the long run, if more young people were exposed to his music. They might even record a cover someday, which would bring him royalties. And to be fair, the real book is actually how I learned who Steve Swallow was. I think to this day, my songs are played to the extent that they are chiefly because they
但《Real Book》继续存在，被一代又一代的盗版商反复复制。史蒂夫·斯沃洛并不轻视版权问题，但他认为《Real Book》是盗版者的杰作。当他同意帮助学生时，斯沃洛实际上捐赠了他自己的许多歌曲。他认为，如果更多的年轻人接触到他的音乐，从长远来看对他是有利的。他们甚至可能在某天录制翻唱版本，这将为他带来版税。公平地说，《Real Book》实际上是我了解史蒂夫·斯沃洛是谁的方式。我想直到今天，我的歌曲之所以被演奏，主要是因为它们
were available in the real book. It's been a blessing. And as the number of students and elite conservatory jazz programs continued to swell over the next few decades, the real book, with its modern repertoire, reharmonized standards, and beautiful handwriting, became the de facto textbook for this new legion of jazz students, the unofficial of visual handbook of jazz. Just like with old fake books, the success of the real book was a major problem for music publishers. Some companies released their own jazz songbooks, but they never managed to compete with the real book.
在《Real Book》中可以找到。这是一种福气。随着在接下来的几十年里，精英音乐学院爵士乐项目的学生人数持续膨胀，《Real Book》凭借其现代曲目、重新编配的标准曲和漂亮的手写体，成为了这支新爵士乐学生大军的事实上的教科书，非官方的爵士乐视觉手册。就像旧的假书一样，这本书的成功对音乐出版商来说是一个大问题。一些公司发布了自己的爵士乐歌集，但他们从未能与《Real Book》竞争。
It couldn't compete with the real book because it just didn't have all the right songs in it. This is Jeff Schradel. He's an executive at Hall Leonard, a print music publishing company. You know, the real book was illegal so they didn't care about licensing and they just put all the best songs in and didn't pay anyone, which wasn't the right thing to do, but obviously from a competitive standpoint, they had the best book out of the gate. And the popularity of the real book meant that lots of people weren't getting paid for their work. That is, until Jeff Schradel
“它无法与《Real Book》竞争，因为它就是没有收录所有正确的歌曲。”这是杰夫·施拉德尔。他是印刷音乐出版公司Hal Leonard的高管。“你知道，《Real Book》是非法的，所以他们不在乎许可，他们只是把所有最好的歌都放进去，而且不付钱给任何人，这虽然不是正确的事情，但显然从竞争的角度来看，他们从一开始就拥有了最好的书。”《Real Book》的流行意味着很多人没有因为他们的工作得到报酬。直到杰夫·施拉德尔
decided to make a legal version, the real real book. You know, I said, hey, we published jazz fake books and jazz lead sheets and jazz publications of all kinds. And you know, yet the real book is still the book. And, you know, why don't we just publish the real book legally? In the mid-2000s, Jeff Schradel and the publisher Hal Leonard secured the rights to almost every song in the real book and published a completely legal version. You don't need to buy the real book out of the back of someone's car anymore. It's available at your local music shop. And to me, the striking thing about this new version is the way that it looks. We didn't want to make the Hellenored corporate real book. We wanted to maintain that sort of homespawn underground look. We wanted the same card stock,
决定制作一个合法版本，“真正的”《Real Book》。“你知道，我说，嘿，我们出版爵士假书、爵士主旋律谱和各种爵士出版物。然而《Real Book》仍然是那本书。为什么我们不合法地出版《Real Book》呢？”2000年代中期，杰夫·施拉德尔和出版商Hal Leonard获得了《Real Book》中几乎每首歌的版权，并出版了一个完全合法的版本。你不再需要从别人的汽车后备箱里买《Real Book》了。它在当地的乐器店就能买到。对我来说，这个新版本最引人注目的是它的外观。“我们不想制作Hal Leonard公司版的《Real Book》。我们想保持那种手工制作的地下外观。我们想要同样的卡纸，”
we wanted the same logo, we wanted the same binding." And they even wanted the same handwriting. Hall entered actually hired a copyist to mimic the old real book's iconic script and turn it into a digital font, which means a digital copy of a physical copy of one anonymous Berkeley students handwriting from the mid-70s will continue to live on for as long as new editions of the book are published. When Hell Leonard finally published the legal version of the real book in 2004, it was great news if you were a composer with a song in there. You'd finally be getting royalties from the sale of the most popular book of jazz music in the world.
“我们想要同样的标志，我们想要同样的装订。”他们甚至想要同样的手写体。Hal Leonard实际上雇佣了一名抄谱员来模仿旧版《Real Book》标志性的字体，并将其转化为数字字体，这意味着来自70年代中期一位匿名伯克利学生手写体的物理副本的数字副本，将随着该书新版本的出版而继续存在。当Hal Leonard在2004年最终出版《Real Book》的合法版本时，如果你是一位在其中有歌曲的作曲家，那是个好消息。你终于可以从世界上最受欢迎的爵士乐书籍的销售中获得版税了。
But that didn't totally solve the intellectual property problems with the real book, and to understand why not, we're going to take a look at one of the songs inside. It's called Sophisticated Lady and it's on page 376 of the Hellennered Real Book. Sophisticated Lady was first recorded by the legendary pianist Duke Ellington and his band in 1933. A trombonist and Ellington's band named Lawrence Brown had this signature rift that he liked to play, and if you listen to the beginning of Sophisticated Lady, you'll hear it. It's the melody. Here's Laurence Brown talking with journalist Patricia Willard.
但这并没有完全解决《Real Book》的知识产权问题，要理解为什么不，我们将看看里面的一首歌。它叫《Sophisticated Lady》，在Hal Leonard版《Real Book》的第376页。《Sophisticated Lady》最早由传奇钢琴家艾灵顿公爵和他的乐队在1933年录制。艾灵顿乐队里的一位长号手名叫劳伦斯·布朗，他有一个他喜欢演奏的标志性乐句，如果你听《Sophisticated Lady》的开头，你会听到它。这就是旋律。这是劳伦斯·布朗与记者帕特里夏·威拉德的谈话。
Who wrote sophisticated lady? Everybody jumps in and helps out, but to me, I had a theme that I played all the time, which is the first eight bars. That was the basic tune of sophisticated lady. But according to Brown, Ellington paid him $15 for his contribution to the song. And I got the terrific check for $15 for a flake, for right, it's specifically lady. Ah, now, have you ever gotten co-composed for credit? No, no, that chick can't sit you out. That means that Brown wasn't legally entitled to a songwriter credit or royalties, even though
“谁写了《Sophisticated Lady》？每个人都跳出来帮忙，但对我来说，我有一个一直演奏的主题，也就是前八小节。那是《Sophisticated Lady》的基本曲调。”但据布朗说，艾灵顿为他在歌中的贡献付给了他15美元。“我收到了一张15美元的支票，作为《Sophisticated Lady》的报酬。啊，现在，你有没有获得过共同作曲的署名？没有，没有，那张支票不能让你……”这意味着布朗在法律上没有资格获得词曲作者署名或版税，尽管
he contributed one of the song's most recognizable elements. But Brown thought that sophisticated lady wouldn't even exist without his signature melody, and that Ellington took credit for writing a song that he merely arranged. I told him, I don't consider you a composer. You are a compiler to which his ego boiled over. Ironically, one person who did get co-writing credits on sophisticated lady was Duke Ellington's white manager, Irving Mills.
他贡献了这首歌最容易辨认的元素之一。但布朗认为，如果没有他的标志性旋律，《Sophisticated Lady》甚至不会存在，而且艾灵顿因为写了一首他仅仅是编曲的歌而获得了荣誉。“我告诉他，我不认为你是作曲家。你是一个汇编者。”这让他的自尊心爆发了。讽刺的是，一个确实在《Sophisticated Lady》上获得共同创作署名的人是艾灵顿公爵的白人经理欧文·米尔斯。
What exactly Mills contributed is debated, but it's clear that he used his power to get his name on many of Ellington's songs and reap more royalties for himself. To this day, when you open up the Howell-Entered Reelbook in turn to sophisticated lady, you'll see three listed writers, including Duke Ellington and Irving Mills.
米尔斯到底贡献了什么是有争议的，但很明显，他利用自己的权力让自己的名字出现在艾灵顿的许多歌曲上，并为自己获取更多的版税。直到今天，当你打开Hal Leonard版《Real Book》翻到《Sophisticated Lady》时，你会看到列出的三位作者，包括艾灵顿公爵和欧文·米尔斯。
But one name you won't see is Lawrence Brown. And so while the legalization of the real book did resolve most of its flagrant copyright violations, it didn't clear up authorship disputes like these that go back to the early days of jazz. And there are likely many more musicians just like write, even if those songs appear in the legal real book. Even if we put intellectual property questions aside for a second, the real book still has plenty of critics. The real book, the guys, when they did it, they transcribed things and they chose standard chords that some people were using,
但你不会看到的一个名字是劳伦斯·布朗。因此，虽然《Real Book》的合法化确实解决了其大部分公然的版权侵权行为，但它并没有理清像这样可以追溯到爵士乐早期时代的作者身份纠纷。即使这些歌曲出现在合法的《Real Book》中，也可能有许多像布朗这样的音乐家。即使我们暂时把知识产权问题放在一边，《Real Book》仍然有很多批评者。“《Real Book》，那些家伙，当他们做的时候，他们转录了东西，他们选择了有些人正在使用的标准和弦，”
but not everyone was using those same chords. Carolyn Wilkins teaches ensembles at Berkeley College of Music. And she says that the real book got so popular over the years that people started to treat the versions of the songs inside as definitive. But even though jazz has all these standards, Wilkins says they're not supposed to be played in one standard way. People, especially back in the day, considered putting their original stamp on something to be far more important than playing it, quote unquote, correctly. So they might change a chord here. They might change a note, they might
“但并不是每个人都在使用那些相同的和弦。”卡罗琳·威尔金斯在伯克利音乐学院教授合奏课。她说，《Real Book》多年来变得如此流行，以至于人们开始把里面的歌曲版本视为定义性的。但尽管爵士乐有所有这些标准曲，威尔金斯说它们不应该以一种标准的方式演奏。人们，特别是在过去，认为在某样东西上打上自己的原创印记远比演奏得“正确”重要得多。所以他们可能会在这里改一个和弦。他们可能会改一个音符，他们可能会
decide they like the key of D flat better than the key of D flat. This type of improvisation is much less common in classical music from the last two centuries where authenticity is more about how well you can reproduce what's on the page as precisely as possible. When people play Mozart's piano sonata number 16 and C major, they don't say, you know what, I'm gonna try it in A major this time. And so when musicians play a version of Bye-Bye Blackbird that sounds exactly as it appears in the real book, they're acting more like classical musicians than jazz musicians.
决定他们更喜欢降D大调而不是D大调。这种即兴创作在过去两个世纪的古典音乐中要少见得多，在古典音乐中，真实性更多地在于你能多精确地再现页面上的内容。当人们演奏莫扎特的《C大调第16号钢琴奏鸣曲》时，他们不会说：“你知道吗，这次我要尝试用A大调演奏。”所以当音乐家演奏一个听起来和《Real Book》中完全一样的《Bye-Bye Blackbird》版本时，他们的行为更像古典音乐家而不是爵士乐手。
And once things kind of became standardized into the real book, then you have this thing of people who just always play the same thing the same way, same key, same set of chord changes. Nicholas Peyton is a musician and record label owner, and he compares the real book to a study guide or a cheat sheet, basically a way to distill this complicated art form into a manageable packet of digestible information. But see here becomes a problem when talking about codifying and teaching black music, is you can't teach free rhythmic thought. You can't put that in a book and expect students to grasp it. To Peyton, the music isn't just information to be learned from a book. It's a way of thinking and a form of expression, and it's fundamentally a black cultural phenomenon
“一旦事情在《Real Book》中标准化了，你就会遇到这样一种情况：人们总是以同样的方式、同样的调性、同样的一组和弦进行来演奏同样的东西。”尼古拉斯·佩顿是一位音乐家和唱片公司老板，他把《Real Book》比作学习指南或小抄，基本上是一种将这种复杂的艺术形式提炼成易于消化的信息包的方法。但这里在谈论编纂和教授黑人音乐时出现了一个问题，那就是你无法教授自由的节奏思维。你不能把它写进书里，并期望学生能领会它。对佩顿来说，音乐不仅仅是从书中学到的信息。它是一种思维方式和一种表达形式，它从根本上是一种黑人文化现象，
that can't be taken out of its historical context. It's a communal music, at its essence, and it's a living, breathing organism. It can't be housed or archived in that way. Patent says that reading books like the real book, even going to music school, can only really get you so far. At some point, you're going to have to immerse yourself in the culture of the music. For Peyton and many other musicians, learning directly from elders in person is a crucial part of
不能脱离其历史背景。它本质上是一种公共音乐，是一个活生生的、呼吸着的有机体。它不能以那种方式被安置或存档。佩顿说，阅读像《Real Book》这样的书，甚至去音乐学校，只能让你走得那么远。在某个时候，你必须让自己沉浸在音乐文化中。对于佩顿和许多其他音乐家来说，亲自向长辈学习是
what it means to really know the art form. I think for many people who perhaps don't live in a thriving music culture like a Detroit or New York or New Orleans or Chicago, if you live in Des Moines, Iowa, you know, school might be a good resource in two, but eventually at some point, if you're serious about playing this music, you're going to have to be around people who actually do it. But Carolyn Wilkins says that the real book does have its place in jazz education. Over her years at Berkeley, she's seen how it can be a useful starting place, a tool to bring young jazz musicians together. A traditional real book gives you at least some sense of this is the repertoire. These are the tunes. If you want to walk into a jam session anywhere in the world and unpack your instrument and say,
真正了解这种艺术形式意味着什么的关键部分。“我认为对于许多可能不住在像底特律、纽约、新奥尔良或芝加哥这样繁荣的音乐文化中的人来说，如果你住在爱荷华州的得梅因，你知道，学校可能是一个很好的资源，但最终在某个时候，如果你认真对待演奏这种音乐，你必须和真正做这件事的人在一起。”但卡罗琳·威尔金斯说，《Real Book》在爵士乐教育中确实有一席之地。在伯克利的这些年里，她看到了它如何成为一个有用的起点，一个将年轻爵士乐手聚集在一起的工具。“传统的《Real Book》至少让你对‘这就是曲目’有了一些感觉。这些就是曲子。如果你想走进世界上任何地方的即兴演奏会，拿出你的乐器说，”
can I sit in? These are the tunes that you're going to need. And if you say, all right, we're going to play beautiful love. Boom, now everyone has a real book that, there's beautiful love, D minor, duh, we're ready. But she also says, if you only play songs as they're notated in the real book, and that's as far as you take it, you're not really playing the music the way it's supposed to be played.
“我可以加入吗？这些就是你需要知道的曲子。如果你说，好吧，我们要演奏《Beautiful Love》。砰，现在每个人都有一本《Real Book》，那是《Beautiful Love》，D小调，哒，我们准备好了。”但她也说，如果你只演奏《Real Book》中记谱的歌曲，而这就是你所能达到的全部，那你并没有真正以它应该被演奏的方式演奏音乐。
To do that, you have to go further. Then you go out and listen to 20 different people play it and find different ways, and then ultimately, you must find your own way. After the break, McKellen, I talk about the central mystery of the real book. Who were the two Berkeley students who compiled the first version and sold it around Boston? We go down that rabbit hole after this. you Okay, so we're back with Macal Macavena who reported that story. And Macal, as I understand it, there is a central mystery at the heart of the story. And that's who wrote the real book, the first real book.
要做到这一点，你必须走得更远。然后你出去听20个不同的人演奏它，找到不同的方式，最终，你必须找到你自己的方式。休息之后，我和麦卡尔谈谈《Real Book》的核心谜团。是谁编译了第一个版本并在波士顿周围出售的两个伯克利学生？我们在之后会深入探讨那个兔子洞。好的，我们回来了，和报道那个故事的麦卡尔·麦卡维纳在一起。麦卡尔，据我所知，这个故事的核心有一个谜团。那就是谁写了《Real Book》，第一本《Real Book》。
The identities of the authors have remained anonymous after all these years, but you were determined to try to figure this out. So why did you want to know the identity of the authors? So the real book was just this kind of omnipresent thing when I was, you know, learning jazz in high school. And it didn't even really seem like it had authors to begin with, just like this book that everybody had. And, you know, it just popped out of thin air. And so when
作者的身份多年来一直保持匿名，但你决心试图弄清楚这一点。那么你为什么要了解作者的身份呢？所以《Real Book》在我高中学习爵士乐时就是那种无处不在的东西。它甚至看起来不像是有作者，就像每个人都有的一本书。而且，你知道，它只是凭空冒出来的。所以当
I learned that there was this backstory and there were these people kind of mysterious figures behind the real book, I was just like, I have to know. Part of it too, for me, was really just, you know, the real book had a big impact on my approach to learning jazz in high school, and the guys who put it together, the choices that they made, kind of directed what I was doing, the kind of like this invisible hand, you know, guiding my musical development, and so to kind of try and reach out and find those guys felt weirdly meaningful to me, in a way. That makes sense to me. So, okay, so where did you start?
我了解到有这个背景故事，并且在《Real Book》背后有一些神秘人物时，我只是觉得，我必须知道。对我来说，部分原因也确实是，《Real Book》对我高中学习爵士乐的方法产生了很大的影响，而把它们放在一起的家伙，他们所做的选择，引导了我正在做的事情，就像这种无形的手，你知道，引导着我的音乐发展，所以试图去联系并找到那些家伙对我来说有一种奇怪的意义。这对我来说很有意义。那么，好的，那么你从哪里开始的呢？
So, I started by talking to my high school jazz teacher, Mr. Leonard, who was a student at Berkeley in the late 70s, a couple of years after the real book came out. But he told me that, you know, when he was a student there, no one was really interested in the story behind the real book or where it came from. No, at that point, we were just concerned with trying not to get busted, buying it from the guy in the corner. I don't even remember being much of a topic of discussion.
所以，我首先和我的高中爵士乐老师伦纳德先生谈了谈，他是70年代末在伯克利的学生，在《Real Book》问世几年后。但他告诉我，你知道，当他在那里读书时，没有人真正对《Real Book》背后的故事或它来自哪里感兴趣。“不，在那个时候，我们只关心尽量不被抓到，从拐角处的那个家伙那里买它。我甚至不记得它是一个讨论的话题。”
Okay, so Mr. Leonard is a bust, so where did you turn to next? So next, I talked to Steve Swallow. Steve Swallow was pretty intimately involved in the creation of the book. And obviously he knew who these guys were, but he wasn't about to tell me because they had sworn him to a note of secrecy after they finished and put it out. But still, I asked him, do you have their contact information?
好的，所以伦纳德先生是个死胡同，那么你接下来转向了哪里？所以接下来，我和史蒂夫·斯沃洛谈了谈。史蒂夫·斯沃洛非常深入地参与了这本书的创作。显然他知道这些人是谁，但他并不打算告诉我，因为他们在完成并出版后让他发誓保密。但尽管如此，我还是问他，你有他们的联系方式吗？
Would you be able to reach out on my behalf if you do? And he said, yeah, I think I was in touch with one of them via email maybe like 10 years ago. We've had email contact maybe Jesus. Maybe 10 years ago, but I would try. I would send an email to that address. And if it still works, see what he says. Sure. Okay, here we go. All right. And so he did and it came back, you know, returned to sender, just bounced back immediately. So that was also a dead end. Okay. Yeah, at this point, I'm feeling a little bit frustrated, a little bit stuck, not really
“如果你有的话，你能代表我联系他们吗？”他说：“是的，我想我大约10年前可能通过电子邮件和其中一个人联系过。我们可能有过电子邮件联系，天哪。也许10年前，但我会试试。我会给那个地址发一封电子邮件。如果它还能用，看看他怎么说。”当然。好的，我们开始吧。好的。所以他这样做了，它回来了，你知道，退回给发件人，只是立即弹回。所以那也是一个死胡同。好的。是的，在这一点上，我感到有点沮丧，有点卡住了，真的不知道
sure what to do next. And then, you know, I just start reading everything I can online that anyone is written about the real book. And one day, I'm on this random blog post somewhere on the internet and I scroll down to the comments section and one of the first comments is from a guy who's claiming to be one of the original authors He's saying, you know, I was one of the authors of the real book and he only goes by one letter So no real name he leaves just a letter to sign off on this comment and the letter is B. Mm-hmm. So mysterious.
接下来该做什么。然后，你知道，我开始在网上阅读任何人写的关于《Real Book》的所有内容。有一天，我在互联网上某个随机的博客文章上，我向下滚动到评论区，第一条评论来自一个声称是原始作者之一的家伙。他说，你知道，我是《Real Book》的作者之一，他只用了一个字母。所以没有真实姓名，他只留下了一个字母来签署这条评论，那个字母是B。嗯，太神秘了。
Very mysterious. This B guy, he also says he was in touch with Barry Kernfeld, who is a musicologist who I had actually already interviewed for this piece. Okay, okay. So how do you know that the person who wrote this comment was the person who actually wrote the real book and not just somebody claiming to be, because I could go on a message word and say, I wrote the real book too, you know. Yeah, totally. So I actually reached out to Barry Kernfeld again after I'd interviewed him and I asked, is this legit?
非常神秘。这个B先生，他还说他曾与Barry Kernfeld联系过，Barry是一位音乐学家，我实际上已经为这篇文章采访过他了。好吧，好吧。那么你怎么知道写这条评论的人就是真正写那本书的人，而不是随便什么人冒充的呢？因为我也可以在留言板上说，我也写了那本真正的书，你知道的。是的，完全同意。所以我实际上在采访完Barry Kernfeld之后又联系了他，我问他，这是真的吗？
Did you get an email from this guy where you in contact with him? This guy who said he was in contact with you who claims to do it for it in the real book? And Barry said, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, okay. He said, actually about 10 years ago, he got an email from this guy and you know, that they were in contact and he said,
你收到过这个人的邮件吗？你们有联系吗？这个说他和你联系过，并声称他参与了那本真正的书的人？Barry说，是的。哦，是的。哦，好吧。他说，实际上大约10年前，他收到了这个人的邮件，你知道，他们有过联系，他说，
he actually still had that email. And so I had to ask him, obviously, can you get back in touch? Can you email this guy again? And he said, sure, I'll try. It's been a long time, but I'll give it a shot. So Barry reached out to the sky. Couple days later, he tells me to reach out directly.
他实际上还保留着那封邮件。所以我不得不问他，显然，你能重新联系上他吗？你能再给这个人发邮件吗？他说，当然，我会试试。已经过去很久了，但我会试一试。所以Barry联系了这个人。几天后，他让我直接联系他。
Okay, here we go. I reach out and then a couple days later, I hear back. And it's a message from a ultra encrypted email server based somewhere outside of the United States. And it's someone using an obviously fake name, but it is definitely this guy. It is B. So this is the guy.
好吧，开始了。我联系了他，几天后，我收到了回复。那是一条来自美国境外某个地方的超加密邮件服务器的消息。发件人使用的是一个明显的假名，但这绝对是这个人。这就是B。所以这就是那个人。
I mean, this is the guy. I mean, when you're going through this, is this level of subterfuge? Does it feel necessary or theatrical, or how is it striking you at this point? It feels a little bit over the top. I do feel like I'm corresponding with a double agent deep in the cold war somewhere. But it's also a little bit exciting.
我的意思是，这就是那个人。我的意思是，当你经历这一切时，这种程度的隐瞒？你觉得这是必要的还是戏剧性的，或者此时此刻你有什么感觉？感觉有点夸张了。我确实觉得我正在和冷战深处的某个双重间谍通信。但这也有点令人兴奋。
It's not a huge mystery, but it is mysterious, definitely. So what did this email say? So I asked him if you would want to do an audio interview and predictably, he said, no, then I asked him, you know, do you want to answer a couple questions over email? And he said, sure. And so I sent him an email with a list of questions and waited a couple days, heard nothing back, sent a follow up email, waited a couple more days, heard nothing back, sent another follow-up email, and then this continued for five times, and at this point, I just kind of resigned myself to the
这不是什么惊天大秘密，但确实很神秘。那么这封邮件说了什么？所以我问他是否愿意接受音频采访，不出所料，他说不。然后我问他，你知道，你愿意通过电子邮件回答几个问题吗？他说，当然。所以我给他发了一封包含一系列问题的邮件，等了几天，没有收到回复，发了后续邮件，又等了几天，还是没有回复，又发了一封后续邮件，这种情况持续了五次，此时此刻，我只能接受
fact that I was not going to hear back from him. Yeah, that's too bad. And I just started pursuing different avenues to try and find this guy or one of the guys. I asked my high school jazz teacher again, do you know people from Berkeley, do you know some names? Can you put me in touch with them? And, you know, he got in touch with a teacher of his who passed on some names to me and I started emailing people, not getting, you know, any more responses. I felt like I was kind of circling the drain at this point. And were you pretty resolved at this point that you were never going to hear from this person or find them before we put the story out. Yeah, I was like, we're never gonna hear back. I was so close and we lost the thread.
我不会收到他回复的事实。是的，太糟糕了。我开始寻找不同的途径来尝试找到这个人或其中一个人。我再次问我的高中爵士乐老师，你认识伯克利的人吗，你知道一些名字吗？你能帮我联系他们吗？而且，你知道，他联系了他的一位老师，转达了一些名字给我，我开始给人们发邮件，没有得到任何回复。我觉得我当时已经走投无路了。在我们在发布这个故事之前，你是否已经下定决心你永远不会收到这个人的回复或找到他们？是的，我想，我们永远不会收到回复了。我离真相那么近，却失去了线索。
It's not coming back. So where are we now? Well, four days before this episode was set to air, I opened my email, it's about 10 p.m. I'm ready to go to sleep. And it's an email from B. Yes. With answers to all of our questions. Oh, nice. So what did they have to say for themselves?
它不会回来了。那么我们现在在哪里？好吧，在这个节目播出前四天，我打开了我的邮箱，大约是晚上10点。我准备睡觉了。这是一封来自B的邮件。是的。回答了我们所有的问题。哦，太好了。那么他们对自己有什么要说的吗？
Like, what kind of questions did you ask? So we asked kind of the gamut, really, of everything related to, you know, from handwriting, you know, was it his handwriting? How do you feel about that handwriting being, you know, from handwriting, you know, was it his handwriting? How do you feel about that handwriting being, you know, omnipresent in real books throughout the world to like, how did it feel to create this thing that some people have, you know, major beefs or major problems with in terms of how it's affected jazz. Yeah. And he had answers to all of those questions.
比如，你问了什么样的问题？所以我们问了各种各样的问题，真的，所有相关的问题，你知道，从笔迹，你知道，那是他的笔迹吗？你对那种笔迹在世界各地的真实书（Real Book）中无处不在有什么感觉？比如，创造这个东西感觉如何，有些人对它如何影响爵士乐有很大的不满或很大的问题。是的。他对所有这些问题都有答案。
So was it his handwriting? It was. He says, yes, the handwriting is mine, although it looks amateurish to me now, but it's quite a hoot to see it everywhere. Someone created a real book font based on my hand. It's close, but no cigar. Wow.
所以那是他的笔迹吗？是的。他说，是的，笔迹是我的，虽然我现在看起来觉得很业余，但看到它到处都是真是太有趣了。有人根据我的手写体创建了一种真实书字体。很接近，但还不够完美。哇。
Throw it throwing a little bit of shade at how Leonard there. You know, did they have a sense of the phenomenon that it was going to become when they were making it? Definitely not. So on that note, he says, we had no idea in our wildest dreams that would become the phenomenon that it is. Countless times, we've personally seen the real book used in bars, clubs, schools, and
这有点在贬低Leonard。你知道，他们在制作它的时候，是否意识到它会成为一种现象？绝对没有。关于这一点，他说，我们做梦也没想到它会成为现在的这种现象。无数次，我们亲眼看到真实书在酒吧、俱乐部、学校和
wedding receptions. It's everywhere. In 2018, I visited a friend of a cousin who had a home recording studio and there were six real books scattered around the room. And if he's keeping up this level of secrecy, you can't just point to him and say, hey, I did that. Yeah, it was a really tough temptation. If I'm like, if I see my book that the Kurt and I did for nine percent of us will out in the world, you bet. I'm going to say, well, hey, I'm that guy. So he said to do that for like 40 years and never seen me.
婚礼招待会上被使用。它无处不在。2018年，我拜访了一位表亲的朋友，他有一个家庭录音室，房间里散落着六本真实书。如果他保持这种保密程度，你就不能指着他说，嘿，那是我做的。是的，这真是一个巨大的诱惑。如果我看到我和Kurt为我们9%的人制作的书在世界上流传，你打赌。我会说，嘿，我就是那个人。所以他说要那样做40年，却从来没被发现。
You know, I guess, you know, some of the bigger issues with the real book that we talk about, you know, the kind of, you know, the copyright and the codification of a style. Did he have any sort of insight into that kind of thing? Yeah. It's really interesting what he said about that. So, and now I'm quoting directly from what he wrote to me. The real book truly changed the world in many good ways, but also not so good. The intent was to create a tool for learning tunes, but not something to be used on the bandstand. It's proliferation into clubs created a negative effect, seemingly dictating
你知道，我想，你知道，我们谈论的关于真实书的一些更大的问题，你知道，那种，你知道，版权和风格的编纂。他对此类事情有什么见解吗？是的。他说的关于这一点的内容非常有趣。所以，现在我直接引用他写给我的话。真实书确实在许多方面改变了世界，但也有些方面不太好。其目的是创建一个学习曲目的工具，而不是在乐队演奏时使用的东西。它在俱乐部中的扩散产生了负面影响，似乎在支配
what and how to play. Wow, well, that's, we really hit the nail on my head. And actually even more on that, he says, never was there any intent to codify anything. The book was meant to help people learn tunes, and beyond what is in the book, it's the responsibility of the musician to listen to as many versions as possible to form one's own sense of how to play the tune. That's why we listed some different recording sources at the bottom of tunes. Every recording has its own tempo and key melodic interpretation form and reharmonizations and therein lie many opportunities to create your own version.
演奏什么以及如何演奏。哇，好吧，我们真的说到了点子上。实际上，关于这一点，他说，从来没有任何编纂任何东西的意图。这本书旨在帮助人们学习曲目，除了书中的内容，音乐家的责任是尽可能多地听不同版本，以形成自己对如何演奏这首曲目的理解。这就是为什么我们在曲目底部列出了一些不同的录音来源。每段录音都有自己的节奏、调式、旋律诠释、形式和重新编配，其中蕴含着许多创造自己版本的机会。
Wow, that is so interesting. Because he basically agrees with most of the critiques of the real book that people had when you talk to them. Yeah, he's essentially saying almost the exact same thing that Carolyn Wilkins said, the Berkeley professor that we talked to towards the end of the piece, basically almost even word for word. It's kind of amazing. And what's also striking is that he basically says the same thing that Nicholas Payton, who is the musician that we talked to, also said about the real book. You know, if you remember, Nicholas Payton was saying that you can't really learn jazz from a book at all. And B, in his answer, says, I think books are fine for theory and learning tunes, but no
哇，这太有趣了。因为他基本上同意人们在与你交谈时对真实书的大部分批评。是的，他本质上说的几乎和Carolyn Wilkins说的一模一样，那是我们在文章结尾采访的伯克利教授，基本上几乎逐字逐句。这真是太神奇了。同样引人注目的是，他基本上说了和Nicholas Payton说的一样的话，Nicholas Payton是我们采访的音乐家，他也谈到了真实书。你知道，如果你还记得，Nicholas Payton说你根本无法从书中真正学习爵士乐。而B在回答中说，我认为书对于理论和学习曲目很好，但没有
amount of book reading will substitute for the actual act of playing music. Feel, timing, groove, and improvisation need to be learned by doing. It's kind of amazing that like he is saying basically the exact same thing that we heard from Nicholas Payton here. Yeah, that's really remarkable. What about this need for anonymity? Like is this something that I mean, obviously at this point, if people knew about it, he's
任何数量的读书能代替实际演奏音乐的行为。感觉、节奏、律动和即兴创作需要通过实践来学习。他说的基本上和我们从Nicholas Payton那里听到的一模一样，这真是太神奇了。这种对匿名性的需求呢？这是否意味着，我的意思是，显然在这一点上，如果人们知道它，他
not going to prosecute for anything really realistically at this point, if people know about it, he's not gonna prosecute for anything really, realistically at this point. So what is that all about? Yeah, you know, it kind of seems like he likes the mystery, and he likes keeping up the mystery. I'm gonna quote again from what he wrote, the internet is full of articles and YouTube videos about the real book, and chat rooms all over the web
在这一点上，如果人们知道它，他实际上不会因为任何事情而被起诉。所以这一切到底是怎么回事？是的，你知道，这看起来他喜欢这种神秘感，并且喜欢保持这种神秘感。我再次引用他写的内容，互联网上到处都是关于真实书的文章和YouTube视频，网络上的聊天室
are rife with discussions about its origins, with zillions of different opinions. That's what's fun about it. Keep the mystery alive. Why mess with an urban legend? You know, I like this guy. Pfft. Pfft.
充斥着关于其起源的讨论，有着无数不同的观点。这就是它的乐趣所在。保持神秘感。为什么要破坏一个都市传说呢？你知道，我喜欢这个人。噗。噗。
I couldn't agree more. Pfft. Let's not mess with it. Let him have his anonymity. I don't think we'll mess with it. Sounds good. Well, thank you, MacKell. I don't think we'll mess with it. Sounds good. Well, thank you, Macal. This was so much fun.
我完全同意。噗。我们不要破坏它。让他保持匿名吧。我不认为我们会破坏它。听起来不错。好吧，谢谢你，MacKell。我不认为我们会破坏它。听起来不错。好吧，谢谢你，Macal。这太有趣了。
Thanks, Roman. Thanks so much. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢，Roman。非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. 29% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Michele McCavinaw, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, music by our director of Sound Sean Rial, mixed by Amidik Anatra. Delaney Hall is a senior producer, Kurt Coltsett is the digital director, the rest of the team is Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Lashemba Dawn, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to author and professor Gerald Hor who we also interviewed for this story. You can check out Nicholas Payton's music at NicholasPayton.com and follow him on Instagram at NicholasPayton.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。本周的《99%隐形》由Michele McCavinaw制作，Emmett Fitzgerald编辑，音乐由我们的声音总监Sean Rial制作，Amidik Anatra混音。Delaney Hall是高级制作人，Kurt Coltsett是数字总监，团队其他成员包括Christopher Johnson、Vivian Leigh、Joe Rosenberg、Lashemba Dawn、Katie Mingle、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。本周特别感谢作者兼教授Gerald Hor，我们也为这个故事采访了他。你可以在NicholasPayton.com查看Nicholas Payton的音乐，并在Instagram上关注他@NicholasPayton。
If you want to read more about the history of fake books, check out Barry Kernfeld's books, pop song, piracy, and the story of fake books. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered across the North American continent right now, but will always be centered in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX,
如果你想了解更多关于假书的历史，请查看Barry Kernfeld的书《流行歌曲、盗版和假书的故事》。我们是旧金山91.7K ALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，目前分散在北美大陆，但将永远以美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为中心。我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的创始成员，
a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world, fun and all, at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 9 on PIorgh, or on Instagram and Reddit too. I am sure there is an entire Reddit thread already devoted to trying to figure out who made the first real book. Don't do it, guys. It doesn't really matter. And mysteries are fun. Instead, spend that energy going through
一个由世界上最具创新性的100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的极其独立的集体，所有这些都可以在radiotopia.fm找到。你可以在Twitter上@RomanMars关注我，在节目上@99PIorg，或者在Instagram和Reddit上也可以。我相信已经有一个完整的Reddit帖子致力于试图找出谁制作了第一本真实书。别这样做，伙计们。这真的不重要。神秘感很有趣。相反，把精力花在
the archive and sharing your favorite episode with a friend at 9-9-PI.org. Radio Topeo. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
浏览档案并与朋友分享你最喜欢的剧集，网址是99PI.org。Radio Topia。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。